your reunion with Christopher Lloyd fans  got so emotional Chris is the best guy  he's going to be this actor that I  worked with that if it was funny and  smart to being a guy who's kind of like  my brother being a guy who's really a  father figure to me now in a way that I  never expected people just like us  together because we remind them of  people that they like when I saw Chris  at the Disco I just threw my arms around  I was so happy to see him how did that  feel to Embrace oh God  I'm not the steadiest Walker these days  all right I beat it across that stage  really fast so I could be there in time  I could meet him when he got there in  his life